[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat pour un nouveau numéro
de 100% Sénat l'émission qui vous fait
vivre les travaux de la Haute Assemblée
la commission d'enquête du Sénat sur le
fond Marianne a commencé ses auditions
les Center veulent faire la lumière sur
ce fond gouvernemental créé en 2021 par
la ministre Marlène chappa pour lutter
contre la radicalisation en ligne le
problème c'est que certaines
associations bénéficiaires de ce fond
Marianne sont suspectés d'avoir mal
utilisé l'argent public notamment à des
fins politiques pour l'une des
associations elle est sénateurs ont
additionné Jean-Pierre Lafitte à
l'actuel secrétaire général adjoint du
comité interministériel de la prévention
de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation un comité chargé du suivi
de ce fond Marianne je vous laisse
écouter cette audition
monsieur secrétaire général adjoint
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues dont nous poursuivons les
auditions de la mission d'information
que notre commission a décidé de
constituée sur la création du fond
Marianne la sélection des projets
subventionnés le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes monsieur Lafitte
d'abord en vous accueillant veuillez
nous excuser pour le retard pris dans
votre audition bien entendu remercions
de votre compréhension
vous êtes magistrat monsieur Lafitte et
secrétaire général adjoint donc du
comité interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation à
ce titre vous avez participé au contrôle
de l'exécution de fond Marianne votre
audition est donc apparue complémentaire
à celle de Monsieur Gravel
avant néanmoins d'évoquer la phase de
contrôle nous avons relevé que vous ne
faisiez pas partie du comité de
sélection des projets est-ce que vous
savez comment la composition de ce
comité a été arrêtée et y a-t-il une
raison pour laquelle on en fassiez pas
partie dans faisiez pas partie
est-ce que vous aviez tout de même
participer à la sélection des projets et
plus généralement qu'elle était votre
rôle dans la préparation de ces
opérations liées au fond de mariage
avant de vous donner la parole pour un
bref propos liminaire et pour répondre à
ses premières questions si vous le
voulez bien je rappelle que seuls les
membres de la commission des finances
peuvent intervenir lors de cette
audition pour interroger la personne
auditionner cette audition est par
ailleurs diffusée vous le savez en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié
enfin je rappelle comme faut témoignage
devant une commission d'enquête et
passible de sanction pénale
je rappelle ça magistrat excusez-moi je
vais pas plus loin
je vous invite donc Monsieur le
Secrétaire général adjoie a prêté
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité devait la main droite et dites
je le jure
je le jure je vous remercie je vous
laisse à présent la parole
si je puis dire la réponse est ouverte
vous m'entendez
en quelque sorte je vais répondre à ces
brièvement puisque en fait ma réponse
est négative
je n'ai pas participé à la préparation
en tout cas la rédaction je viendrai
après sur le mot préparation mais à la
rédaction de ce qui était ensuite
l'appel à projet
je n'ai pas participé vous l'avez
indiqué à la fin à la définition de la
composition du comité de sélection et je
n'ai pas non plus participé au comité de
sélection et ça je pense que vous l'avez
effectivement tout à fait identifié
alors je ne sais pas je peux pas vous
donner de réponse exacte précise sur la
raison de qui fait qu'effectivement je
n'ai pas eu à être associé à ce comité
ou en tout cas à cette phase de
préparation moi ce que je vois mais
c'est une pure analyse de ma part elle
peut peut-être être contester d'ailleurs
dans des déclarations mais c'est comme
ça je vois les choses c'est qu'en fait
étant depuis d'ailleurs assez peu de
temps à charger des fonctions de
secrétaire général adjoint j'avais été
nommé le 17 décembre 2020 donc ça
faisait 4 mois en fait que j'étais dans
ces fonctions j'avais effectivement des
fonctions essentiellement à caractère
budgétaire financière et donc je suppose
que dans la lecture que faisait à
l'époque le cabinet de la ministre
délégué l'objectif du fond Marianne en
particulier était surtout un objectif
qui avait une finalité de communication
sur les réseaux sociaux et donc une
problématique thématique qui n'est
absolument pas la mienne sur laquelle je
n'exerce et je n'ai d'ailleurs aucune
compétence donc je pense que c'est
probablement la raison qui fait
qu'effectivement la composition que vous
avez cité que l'air je ne connaissais
pas moi je l'ai découvert l'occasion des
investigations qui ont été menées
n'a pas comporté en tout cas cette
dimension ce qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
de mon point de vue mais c'est un point
de vue personnel peut soulever un
certain nombre de questions toujours
est-il que si je n'ai pas participé à la
rédaction de l'appel à projet en lui en
lui-même j'ai quand même et je l'ai
vérifié parce que j'avoue j'avoue
j'avais un peu des doutes deux ans se
sont passés et j'avais pas une mémoire
absolue de toutes les phases qui ont pu
comment dirais-je accompagner
l'appel à projet mais j'ai eu à
participer par contre à une organisation
interne au sein du secrétaire général
quand j'ai été informé et ça a été très
précis c'était le sauf erreur le 13
avril 2021 lors d'une réunion avec le
cabinet de la ministre c'est une réunion
du comité de vie de programmation qui se
distingue je pense que je ne sais pas si
vous avez eu des notions du comité de
sélection concernant spécialement le
fond Marianne et ce 13 avril donc en
réalité sont annoncés par le cabinet non
pas un mais trois appels à projets
l'appel à projet de vie fond Marianne
qui vise le contre discours républicain
essentiellement comme thématique un
appel à projet qui va concerner la
mililude la mission de lutte contre les
tarifs sectaires qui vient d'être
attachés depuis quelques mois seulement
on se cada général c'était en juillet
2020 le décret est publié en juillet
2020 et un troisième appel à projet qui
vise à promouvoir des actions de lutte
contre les atteintes et la dignité
humaine c'est comme ça que c'est
présenté sa vise en particulier des
dispositifs en tout cas c'est comme ça
que c'est évoqué qui par exemple lutte
contre les mariages forcés c'est comme
ça que c'est présenté cet appel à projet
n'aura jamais lieu je le précise il y a
aucune traduction budgétaire il va pas
avoir ta traduction dans plus politique
et il va pas être annoncé publiquement
en tout cas il était évoqué ce jour-là
et donc le 13 avril 2021 étant informé
de ce projet puisque là c'est vraiment
encore au stade du projet il sera
annoncé le bon Marianne en tout cas
l'appel à projet sera annoncé le je
crois faire le 20 avril donc une semaine
après en fait à peu près
je prends l'initiative c'est moi qui ai
pris l'initiative je clairement de
réunir un certain nombre d'acteurs de
Steam paraître les acteurs qui vont être
impactés au sein du service je vous
parle pas du cabinet qui est tout à fait
en dehors de ce dispositif qui risque
d'être impactés par ces trois appels à
projets c'est-à-dire pour moi dans
l'analyse que je fais à ce moment-là
trois pôles métiers alors Paul métier je
sais pas si cette notion vous a été
expliqué mais j'imagine que oui ce sont
en gros les services au sein du
secrétaire général qui par matière
traite de tel ou tel domaine d'activité
de tel ou telle politique publique qui
est confiée au secrétaire général donc
ça s'appelle les pôles métiers par
distinction avec le pôle administratif
et financier qui est un pôle support
celui dont j'ai la responsabilité depuis
donc décembre 2020
et je réunis à priori je pense les
représentants des trois pôles métiers
qui me paraissent de voir ou pouvoir
être impacté par ces trois appels à
projets c'est-à-dire ce qu'on vient de
créer il y a quelques mois ou quelques
semaines qui s'appelle l'ucdr l'unité de
contredes républicains je pense que vous
savez dans quel contexte
l'autorité politique a pris la décision
de nous confier enfin de confiance
locataire général le soin de créer ce
nouvel ce nouveau service ce nouveau
pôle un autre pôle qui est qui n'est pas
un pôle d'ailleurs qui est simplement
rattaché dans la personne du secrétaire
général qui est la mililud donc avec un
acteur qui représente ce service et un
troisième pôle alors je ne sais pas s'il
a été cité qui à l'époque s'appelle il a
changé de nom depuis je crois qu'à
l'époque il devait s'appeler le pôle de
lutte contre l'islamisme bradical et le
communautarisme je crois que c'était un
peu près ça dénomination qui risque
d'être impactée par le troisième appel à
projet que j'ai cité qui finalement ne
verra pas lieu
et surtout je les réuni en fait alors
c'est très précis c'est je l'ai retrouvé
d'ailleurs j'ai sous les yeux d'ailleurs
le compte-rendu de cette région que j'ai
moi-même rédigé que j'ai envoyé au
préfet bien entendu le 22 avril donc
c'est deux jours après le lancement de
l'appel à projet fort mariage et en fait
moi j'ai deux objectifs parce que je
sens venir des difficultés
d'organisation et en fait plusieurs
difficultés à mon esprit en tout cas
peuvent surgir d'abord un problème
d'organisation et surtout de respect des
process
alors je ne sais pas si ce nom a été
cité dans les auditions il y a un
instant du préfet Gravel pour moi c'est
très important parce que j'en suis un
peu en charge nous avons la définition
du process de distribution des
subventions publiques au sein du LG
cipdr
c'est un document qui a été élaboré une
histoire tout ça en 2017 exactement tout
simplement parce que l'année précédente
en 2016 pour la première fois les
crédits du fond interministériel de
prévention de la délinquance sont
confiés en gestion directe au
secrétariat général ce qui n'était pas
le cas avant
c'est la loi de finances pour 2016 donc
du 31 décembre 2015 qui confie qui
supprime plutôt une agence peut-être
connu l'accès l'agence de la cohésion
sociale égalité des chances qui gérait
en fait à l'époque le FIPD le fond est
ministériel en notre nom mais nous
n'avions pas la gestion nous n'avons pas
de Paul administratif et financier à
l'époque et en 2016
la loi de finances supprime donc cette
agence et le après différentes
discussions moi je veux passer là-dessus
bien entendu la gestion nous est confiée
directement et donc en 2016 il faut
créer dans les conditions moi j'ai pas
connu j'étais pas encore dans ce poste
là à l'époque mais un peu complexe il a
fallu créer les Bauges d'un pôle
financier avec des recrutants bien
entendu ce que nous avions aucun
budgétaire aucun fonctionnaire n'était
capable de gérer des crédits à cette
époque là
et en 2017
avec des recrutements notamment je crois
d'un secrétaire général adjoint à
l'époque il n'était pas moi je suis
arrivé bien plus tard
et mis en place une politique qui est se
mettait en place à l'époque au ministère
de l'Intérieur qui a la politique de
maîtrise des risques de contrôle des
risques
et notamment en 2017 au sein du service
qui est le nôtre parce que nous avons le
FIP à gérer on met en place un
document que nous appelons logigramme
alors c'est un document un grand tableau
excel avec différentes cases et
notamment des colonnes dans lesquelles
en fait on sait ce que j'évoque quand
j'en parle on définit qui fait quoi qui
fait quoi pour gérer le subvention en
centrale ce document était élaboré en
2017 il est révisé en 2018 il est à
nouveau révisé en 2019 et en 2021 quand
l'appel a projet fort Marianne est lancé
c'est cette version 2019 qui s'applique
qui à mon avis n'est plus à jour
d'ailleurs mais bon ça c'est une autre
histoire sur laquelle je suis j'ai dû
revenir mais encore récemment mais en
tout cas il est plus à jour pour une
raison très précise c'est que entre
temps nous sommes je pense alors j'ai
pas retrouvé la date exacte mais je
pense que c'est entre fin 2020 et
peut-être avril 2021 quand soutient le
fameux comité de programmation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le cabinet de
Madame chapard à l'époque le ministre
délégué décide d'élever à son niveau la
prise de décision sur l'attribution des
crédits par des subventions centrales
jusqu'à présent le secrétaire général le
secrétariat général le secrétaire
général décidait seul de l'attribution
des subventions avec les crédits que
nous réservions en centrale sur des
actions de portée nationale en tout cas
nous certainement c'était le secrétaire
général c'est lui qui décidait en
réunion comité de programmation en
interne au sein du service ses décisions
et avec l'arrivée donc du nouveau
cabinet de la nouvelle ministre la
décision est prise à son niveau de
d'élever à son niveau politique donc la
prise de décision d'où la mise en place
des comités de programmation
ministérielle cette fois-ci et je répète
j'ai fait des recherches a priori le
premier semble être celui du 13 avril
2021 moi je vais pas trouver trace d'un
comité précédent fin 2020 ou début 2021
je pense que c'est le premier et donc
quand l'appel à projet donc est lancé
le 22 avril donc très précisément je
réunis dans un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui sont des acteurs métiers vraiment
qui pour certains d'ailleurs ne
connaissent pas du tout la matière parce
que je veux rappeler quelles sont les
règles et figurent dans le fameux
logigramme qui fait quoi
et donc je le rappelle qu'il appartient
alors je veux pas définir tout le
gigrane parce qu'il fait il y a 12 cases
12 étapes à l'époque qu'on a des
renforcé très récemment en 14 étapes et
12 étapes ou en gros on doit définir qui
reçoit la demande subvention qui
instruit le dossier qui doit vérifier
les pièces constitutives du dossier qui
doit ensuite
mon pôle mon service mettre en forme les
actes attributifs de subventions qui
contrôlent également ensuite l'exécution
reçoit des documents soit venant des
pôles métiers soit venant en termes
budgétaire des associations qui doivent
rendre compte c'est la loi de
l'exécution de la subvention donc tout
cela est défini or le 22 avril 2021 et
ça je tiens à insister
sur les trois pôles donc je réunis ce
jour là
un seul agent connaît la matière
c'est celui alors je ne sais pas s'ils
ont été cités peu importe c'est celui
c'est celle d'ailleurs qui va instruire
les dossiers du fond Marianne c'est
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude depuis alors
je sais pas combien de temps mais
probablement moins 2 ans ou un an et
demi deux ans à instruire déjà des
dossiers de demande de subvention
notamment sur le contre discours
républicain c'est ça c'est son domaine
c'est le connaît et elle connaît un peu
la matière elle sait quelles sont les
documents à réunir etc par contre en
face sur les deux autres pôles alors je
vais passer rapidement parce que c'est
pas le sujet aujourd'hui bien entendu
mais c'est important pour moi parce que
c'est comme ça que j'ai vécu des choses
on a des agents qui ne connaissent
absolument rien la matière budgétaire et
je pense notamment à la migélude j'ai un
agent en face de moi qui n'a jamais
entendu parler de ce que c'est qu'une
subvention son statut juridique le cas
dans lequel on peut distribuer quelles
sont les pièces à demander il y a tout à
fait
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
cette réunion a lieu où je rappelle un
certain nombre de rectif figure dans le
fameux Logicom et un deuxième point
important pour moi c'est de demander aux
responsables de ces pôles métiers de
désigner un référent parce que je
pressens que nous allons avoir des
difficultés je sais pas si ça a été
évoqué mais c'est aussi un plan très
important à cette époque c'est un
problème de ressources humaines
je ferais sans que nous allons avoir des
difficultés cette fois-ci dans le pôle
d'Angers la responsabilité sur le pollen
pratique financier parce que nous avons
un effectif extrêmement réduit très
tendu à cette époque là et que ça va
durer encore pendant des mois et les
mois et donc je souhaite que un référent
nommé pour que on ait un correspondant
qu'on puisse le cas échange en forme et
d'ailleurs à la matière budgétaire ce
qui va être fait pour la migélitude ce
qui ne sera pas fait pour le pôle qui va
instruire les dossiers du fond Marianne
puisque à Torro a raison je pense que
c'est avec raison j'estime que l'agent
est formé à cette matière l'a déjà
instruit de nombreux dossiers mais par
contre on va le faire pour l'individu et
on va faire des séances de formation
avec un document qu'on va remettre etc
pour expliquer là aussi quels sont les
rôles
alors c'est là où se situe mon rôle en
tout cas dans un premier temps
c'est-à-dire une organisation interne
une espèce de rappel des process pour
que effectivement on évite des
difficultés ensuite de gestion etc
sauf que évidemment cette situation ne
puisse pas le sujet des moyens
disponibles et du contexte dans lequel
se situe le fonds Marianne
même si il n'y aura dans l'année 2021
que deux appels à projets formalisés ce
qui est exact c'est un une année je
pense que je me trompe pas dans les
chiffres c'est l'année où nous avons
enregistré le nombre record de demandes
de subvention à instruire au niveau
central
c'est des chiffres que j'ai fournis
d'ailleurs
je sais pas si ça a été dit une étude de
le Cours des comptes aussi assez six
mois dans nos locaux enfin notamment
avec moi pour l'aspect interministériel
et j'ai remis un certain nombre de
chiffres de données et en fait il
apparaissait quelqu'un il apparaît que
2021 enregistre pratiquement une
centaine de demandes de subventions 98
je crois c'est le chiffre exact alors
qu'un des précédentes on a été une
cinquantaine les années d'avant c'était
une trentaine donc une année record des
effectifs qui sont en tension notamment
sur le strict domaine financier dont
j'ai la responsabilité en fait le pôle
dont je viens la responsabilité je vous
le dis pour que les choses soient
claires c'est deux agents
un troisième qui a été recruté au mois
de mars mais qui n'est absolument pas
formé à cette matière qui ne connaît
rien d'ailleurs à cette matière là qui
gère le budget de fonctionnement donc on
est tout à fait éloigné de ce domaine en
revanche ces deux agents qui eux sont
formés mais avaient des compétences
totalement distinctes il y en a un qui
est chargé de ce qu'on appelle le budget
opérationnel le programme le bob racine
des crédits du FIPD de façon à déléguer
les crédits non seulement au niveau
central mais surtout en préfecture parce
que je pense que ça a été dit mais c'est
très important l'essentiel du fond ce
sont des crédits destinés aux
préfectures de département c'est ça
c'est 54 millions je crois j'ai pas les
chiffres en tête exacts pour 2021 cette
année je les connais par contre en 2021
ça doit être à peu près 60 ou 65
millions au niveau tout compris la
notification de départ par le secrétaire
général du ministère de l'Intérieur et
c'est 54 millions qui sont destinés donc
aux préfecture donc l'essentiel est
crédible et c'est cet agent qui gère les
rapports quotidiens avec la préfecture
sur ces sujets là et le deuxième agent
qui est une jeune femme d'ailleurs
c'est elle qui va instruire enfin
instruire mettre en forme pardon les
l'ensemble des dossiers du fond Marianne
donc ils vont résulter de l'arbitrage du
20 avril mais en réalité du 21 mai
pardon mais en réalité qui met en forme
tous les dossiers les 98 dossiers en
fait de l'année 2021 ce que j'ai n'est
pas tout à fait exact et c'est un cas
tout à fait exceptionnel parce que je
j'avoue j'avais tout info perdu la
mémoire de cet aspect là que j'ai revu
en disant les mails que j'ai reçu sur
ces sujets c'est qu'en fait je crois que
c'est la seule fois que c'est arrivé en
tout cas quand j'ai eu cette
responsabilité de secrétaire général
adjoint c'est que exceptionnellement
cette année là notamment au cours de
l'été 2021 compte tenu de la masse de
travail importante qui lire déstabilise
un peu je veux dire les choses comme ça
le service l'agent qui a instruit les
dossiers du fond Marianne donc celui qui
appartient à un autre pôle qui n'est pas
sous ma responsabilité va accepter de
mettre en forme un certain nombre de
conventions budgétaires attributif de
subventions parce qu'il faut soulager
mon service qui n'est pas en mesure dans
les délais de mettre en forme
précisément tous ces actes alors il y a
un délai vous connaissez qui évidemment
celui de l'exercice budgétaire c'est à
dire que aux alentours du 10 décembre
chaque année la direction financière du
ministère à l'intérieur la dépit nous
rappelle que à un moment donné ce clos
l'engagement des autorisations
d'engagement les délivrance et la
consommation des crédits de paiement et
qu'on peut pas dépasser les dates avec
le nombre de dossiers de l'année il
fallait évidemment trouver les moyens
pour résoudre cette difficulté c'est ce
qui est fait j'ai retrouvé les mails de
sa part où elle me soumet pendant le
mois de juillet surtout juillet août je
crois un certain nombre de pas tous les
dossiers mais un certain nombre de
dossiers qui vont résulter donc de
l'appel à projet fond Marianne de façon
ce que je puisse les contrôler et c'est
là où si ils permettent il y a un
deuxième aspect qui apparaît dans mon
rôle sur ces sujets là et qui traduit un
peu les difficultés de cette année là
et notamment du fond Marianne
c'est que
en fait c'est à ce moment-là que je
découvre le contenu des demandes
suivantes c'est pas tout à fait exact il
y a une exception
l'exception c'est l'association je pense
que vous avez en tête qui s'appelle l'US
OPM
parce que cette association en fait a
présenté une demande subvention avant le
fond Marianne avant l'appel à projet
enfin en tout cas la connaissance
publique de l'appel à projet elle envoie
à priori je pense au secrétaire général
pour probablement moi c'est comme ça que
j'ai compris les choses qui ensuite me
retourne des documents une demande de
subvention
de mémoire je pense que c'est le 9 avril
2021 donc effectivement on est quelques
jours avant le l'appel à projet la
délivrance et ce jour-là je découvre
donc pour la première fois une
association que je ne connais absolument
pas et qui demande des sommes très
importantes
extrêmement importantes c'est un montant
de l'ordre de mémoire 635000 euros
ce qui est quand même surprend je lui
dis clairement et je fais un mail en
réponse ce qui me surprend parce que ça
nous sommes quand même considérable et
surtout une association qu'on n'a jamais
financée enfin a priori jamais moi je ne
connais pas du tout
qui est alors c'est très ancienne qui a
peut-être une certaine notoriété d'une
certaine que je ne connais pas mais en
tout cas il y a un indien point alors
premier point qui m'a l'air de ce
montant et le deuxième point c'est qu'en
plus dans le budget prévisionnel qui est
présenté il y a un déséquilibre mais au
bénéfice de l'association c'est à dire
qu'il y a un excédent qui résulte de la
colonne produit et charge bon alors
c'est pas interdit je le dis au passage
quelque chose soit clair et on accepte
parfois sauf que ce qui est interdit ce
qui est autorisé plutôt c'est ce qu'on
appelle un excédent raisonnable
or là l'excédent pareil quand même je
sais plus quel est le montant mais en
tout cas suffisamment significatif pour
que j'envoie une réponse un mail au
secrétaire général en disant mais en
écrivant que ça me paraît inacceptable
en l'état association qui n'est pas
connue montant considérable excédent qui
apparaît dans le budget prévisionnel
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
problématique alors cette demande va
être examinée au comité de programmation
du 13 avril c'est exact et dans les
documents qu'on a revu récemment parce
que il a fallu rafraîchir la mémoire je
le cache pas il apparaît un montant
arbitré le 13 avril je dis bien pas le
21 mai c'est le 13 avril de 300.000
euros
c'est ce qui apparaît dans un tableau
que nous restitue après le réunion de ce
comité de programmation
pour des raisons qui peut-être ont été
commentés je ne sais pas il y a un
instant ce dossier en fait va intégrer à
un moment donné l'appel à projets fort
Marianne condition que moi je ne
maîtrise pas réellement mais en tout cas
c'est une réalité puisqu'il va
réapparaître dans les dossiers qui vont
être examinés apparemment le 21 mai et
qui surtout vont être arbitrés et
retenus pour un montant de 355000 euros
exactement donc ça c'est le dossier
c'est le choix si je me trompe pas je
pense ne pas me tromper c'est le seul
dossier dont j'ai eu connaissance en
partie dans son contenu avant la
réception des je ne sais plus quoi 70 71
dossier je crois au total qui a reçu
l'agent qui était chargé de la réception
et surtout de l'instruction des dossiers
et ce qui va se passer par la suite et
c'est là on ne peut pas ne pas venir
c'est que en fait je vais découvrir les
autres dossiers au moment de la
formalisation des accatributifs
c'est-à-dire où mon pôle aidé par
l'agent qui instruit les dossiers en
partie va mettre en forme les actes
attributifs alors je pense que vous
savez qu'il y a deux types d'actes selon
les montants ça c'est la loi de 2000 du
12 avril 2000 qui a été modifié en 2014
qui comporte ses dispositions
c'est l'article 10 sauf erreur de cette
loi en fait il y a un seuil à partir
duquel la forme de l'acte est un acte
bilatéral
en deçà de 23000 euros le seuil est fixé
par décret mais la loi prévoit le
principe en deçà de 23000 euros c'est un
acte unilatéral c'est un arrêté et donc
le secrétaire général signe un arrêté
l'attributif au delà de 23000 euros
c'est une convention donc avec double
signature les contrôles aussi du contenu
plus exigeantes dans sa formalisation où
là il y a effectivement quand même des
exigences assez fortes de contrôle et la
plupart des appels d'affaires des
dossiers de l'appel à projeter Marianne
rentreront dans la catégorie des
conventions ils seront au-delà de 23000
euros de mémoire il y en a deux je crois
il y a deux arrêtés et le reste donc 15
logiquement qui sont les conventions
et donc cette aspect là donne lieu
effectivement à cette rédaction et à ce
moment-là que je vois effectivement
apparaître un certain nombre de montants
qui ont été arbitrés ils intervient le
21 mai et il y en a un qui attire mon
attention je dis aussi il y a des mails
de ma part que j'ai retrouvé que j'ai
imprimé parce que encore une fois c'est
la mémoire ensuite qui a besoin d'être
réactivé il y en a un qui je vois pas
lui CPPM cette fois-ci je parle d'une
autre association qui s'appelle
reconstruire le commun
où là je découvre mon temps relativement
important quand même avec une
association qui a déjà été financée avec
une petite convention si je puis dire de
39000 euros dans des conditions un peu
compliquées d'ailleurs fin 2020 début
2021 où je suis arrivé où je découvre un
peu la difficulté de ce dossier mais
c'était pas un montant aussi
significatif et j'envoie un certain
nombre de commentaires par mail là aussi
sur cette association en indiquant
qu'elle est récente qu'elle a bénéficié
d'un montant significatif important et
surtout et c'est un des critères moi que
j'essaie de voir parce que c'était très
difficile enfin je sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu ce qu'on appelle les CERFA de
demande de subvention c'est pas très
facile de comprendre ce qu'on a derrière
le CERFA c'est vraiment il faut parfois
il y a quelques critères parfois un peu
significatif et c'est pas toujours
simple il y en a un moi j'essaie de
retenir c'est quels sont les moyens
humains de la structure quand elle
reçoit beaucoup d'argent pour gérer
l'argent
s'il y a personne c'est une
interrogation et c'est le cas pour
reconstruire le commun alors ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des bénévoles
capables c'est toute la complexité des
associations il y a parfois des
bénévoles et des retraités ou que
sais-je qui sont des experts-comptables
qui sont des magistrats ou autre
peut-être parfois des élus nationaux
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas qui ont
bien sûr des compétences c'est évident
mais quand vraiment qu'on n'a pas
d'information sur le sujet et qu'on voit
que c'est tel cas de cette association
les effectifs alors je sais pas je crois
que c'était un salarié ou un 0,5 TP
quelque chose comme ça qui apparaît dans
le CERFA alors qu'il y a quand même pu
300 + 300.000 euros qui est 330 000
euros qui sont distribués ça a l'air
d'un petit peu encore une fois c'est pas
un critère absolument d'iriment mais ça
peut provoquer quand même quelques
alertes sauf que la décision a été prise
évidemment elle était arbitrée cabinet
il faut l'exécuter et enfin je mets
quand même en alerte l'ensemble des
acteurs donc le seul qui est instruit le
dossier mais aussi mon pôle en disant il
va falloir quand même surveiller un peu
cette association parce que il y a quand
même ce équilibre là qui peut poser des
difficultés peut-être avant
si vous voulez bien peut-être s'en tenir
à cette phase qui était un peu la
première partie des questions on va vous
demander quelques compléments on a eu
d'ailleurs copies de quelques uns de vos
mails qui vont dans le sens que vous
indiquez mais vrai que le rapporteur
reprécise quelques points et puis
poursuivre si vous voulez bien pardon
monsieur Lafitte moi je vais
je vous ai écouté j'ai besoin de d'avoir
des clarifications d'être sûr que
on sait bien enfin j'ai bien compris vos
propos vous nous avez expliqué quel
était votre fonction quand vous êtes
arrivé finalement depuis peu décembre
2020 vous avez bien expliqué que pour
les comités ministériels de
programmation le premier étant a priori
dans la nouvelle procédure celui du 13
avril
qu'il y a finalement une procédure
juridique enfin administrative et
juridique très établie avec les 12
étapes qu'il faut suivre donc vous me
confirmez que voilà ça c'est la première
chose ça permet d'éclaircir vous nous
avez également dit je suis la
chronologie de vos propos
que dans dans le pôle il y avait en fait
peu de compétences en matière comptable
et budgétaire
une une seule personne
pouvez-vous nous donner
son nom alors quand on parle du pôle
métier concerné pour bien préciser les
choses l'agent qui avait une formation
qui avait une connaissance d'instruction
des dossiers c'est Charlotte Collonge
qui a pris je crois la totalité enfin
j'en suis pas sûr c'est à dire j'avais
bien imaginé la même personne voilà
puisque on voit qu'il y a un lien
ensuite lorsqu'elle quitte le service
merci
à alors on arrive j'arrive toujours dans
les éléments dont vous nous que vous
avez porté à notre connaissance
le fait d'avoir l'usé ppm qui avant même
le comité
de programmation et donc avant le
lancement officiel du fond Marianne
adresse une demande de subvention
au comité
interministériel d'un montant de 635 000
euros donc effectivement et vous dites
je ne connais pas j'ai aucun
renseignements et le montant enfin je le
conseille volontiers et très élevé vous
avez même dit qu'il y avait ensuite dans
la présentation comptable à un excédent
significatif
et ensuite alors sont retirés je crois
300.000 euros vous pouvez me
réexpliquer comment on passe de 635 000
à 335 et quel est l'opération qui était
effectuée pour le retrait de ces 300000
euros alors ce que je sais moi à travers
les documents qu'on a pu relire je
répète la mémoire n'est pas extrêmement
présente sur toutes les étapes l'avouer
c'est une décision qui a été pris en
comité de programmation ministérielle
donc le 13 avril a priori là parce que
je perçois et là mais dans un contexte
que je mangeais pas le souvenir il y a
eu effectivement une décision de
rabattre sensiblement la prétention
effectivement ce jour-là le comité
retient 335 000 ou 350 300000 je crois
oui il en est il retire 300000 voilà il
en reste je pense 335 il me semble tout
à l'heure vous avez 355 mais on va pas
je cherche pas à basé sur les sur les
montants mais enfin moi ça me paraît
assez cohérent ensuite vous nous avez
expliqué la procédure qui laisse la main
au comité jusqu'à 23000 euros puisque
c'est discrétionnel au-delà c'est
forcément une convention et donc ça
n'est plus discrétionnaire puisqu'il
faut une double signature
vous avez expliqué vous avez employé les
mots que vous avez eu dans des
conditions difficiles inversement de
39000 euros est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus les conditions difficiles
ou la
expliquer enfin quel était le contexte
qui des difficultés il y a une
difficulté alors j'ai pas je pense que
je ne t'ai pas présent à ce moment-là
parce que ça s'est passé à la fin de
l'année 2020 et j'avais encore j'avais
pas les responsabilités que j'ai eu donc
à la fin de l'année on a eu en fait des
difficultés pour identifier le l'acte
juridique qui était à l'origine de la
délivrance de cette somme
qu'il existe un je vous rassure je pense
qu'il y a pas eu de difficultés sur son
existence mais il y en a du mal à
l'identifier dans un premier temps et ça
tient à priori au fait que il y a eu une
décision je n'ai pas retrouvé la trace
je le dis clairement j'ai encore
rechercher récemment j'ai pas trouvé la
trace mais elle existe puisqu'il y a eu
une convention qui a été qui a été
passée qui date de la fin de l'année
2020 le document le document lui-même
l'acte attributif c'est une convention
signée des deux parties donc le
secrétaire général et le représentant de
l'association la représentante
d'ailleurs c'est une présidente et dater
exactement du 28 décembre 2020
or le 28 décembre 2020 c'est à un moment
où il y a plus de crédit disponible
pour attribuer une subvention je ne sais
pas dans quel contexte elle avait eu
lieu mais en tout cas cet acte on l'a
fini par le retrouver et c'est le 28
décembre et en fait ce qui est découvert
c'est que on a des tableaux de suivi
dans mon pôle enfin vraiment service à
moi en Suisse chaque convention pour
savoir quand on délivre le premier
acompte quand il y a des acomptes et
quand on délivre le solde quand il y a
un solde et on trouve une trace
effectivement de cette cette convention
de 2020 je dis bien par contre il y a
une mention qui indique que elle est
basculée je dis c'est le terme basculer
en 2021 pour des raisons d'ailleurs
budgétaires strictement et donc en fait
on retrouve effectivement la trace de
cette subvention qui a été versé mais en
2021 avec les crédits une fois que la
direction financière enfin le secrétaire
général du ministère nous un notifié des
crédits on a pu attribuer les crédits
qui avaient été décidé l'année d'avant
avant on pouvait pas parce que une
libert l'action sur le plan budgétaire
donc d'une certaine manière je veux
être sûr qu'il y aurait pas
d'interprétation
inappropriée ouative une subvention est
attribuée le 28 décembre à une période
où il y a plus les moyens et puis il y a
plus de crédit un peu plus tard entre
guillemets on procède au versement en
disant qu'elle a été attribuée l'an
passé l'année passée alors qu'il y avait
plus de fonds en gros c'est c'est à peu
près ça ce qui est-ce que j'exagère en
disant que peut-être ça limite le
contrôle
alors je sais pas si ça limite le
contrôle en tout cas ça aboutit à une
situation qui est à mon avis discutable
et dont on va se rendre compte
d'ailleurs plus tard mais beaucoup plus
tard trop tard d'ailleurs probablement
pour remettre en cause d'ailleurs
l'attribution c'est que en fait l'action
va s'exécuter en 2021
sauf que la convention d'origine de 2020
normalement aurait dû permettre
l'imputation des charges sur l'exercice
2020 je dis bien or l'exécution va se
faire en 2021 et donc les dépenses aussi
forcément et on a regardé les
investigations il y a quelques semaines
on a regardé si on a trouvé la trace
d'un avenant ce qui est possible on peut
effectivement ça arrive parfois et c'est
beaucoup arrivé d'ailleurs à cette
époque à cause de la crise sanitaire on
a énormément d'associations qui n'ont
pas pu exécuter en 2020 et même 2021
d'ailleurs leur action pour des raisons
qu'on comprend et il a fallu faire des
avenants pour prolonger la durée
d'exécution ce qui était logique on n'a
pas trouvé de trace dans ce dossier là
en tout cas je le dis d'un avenant qui
aurait encadré juridiquement la
prolongation et pour autant c'est ce qui
va se passer c'est-à-dire les crédits
2021 votre mobilisés
les 39000 euros je crois que c'est du
montant vont être attribués et
l'exécution va être fait il y aura des
comptes rendus le contrat de financier
qui est obligé obligatoire d'après la
loi va être adressée et a priori
d'action a bien été exécuté il
s'agissait de créer un site je crois
internet l'association a été créée je
crois en octobre 2020 ou en tout cas fin
2020 il s'agissait de créer un site
internet et de promouvoir un certain
nombre de dispositifs sur les réseaux
sociaux a priori les comptes rendus en
tout cas sur le plan strictement formel
qui vont être adressés dans le cadre de
cette action montre qu'il y a eu une
action conforme à ce qui avait été
prévue au départ en tout cas en l'état
moi j'ai pas de raison de remettre en
cause l'existence de cette action et sa
réalisation
ce qui est compliqué c'est là le
basculement quelque sorte entre les deux
exercices budgétaires
est-ce que vous aviez fini parce que je
vous ai interrompu je voulais pas perdre
le fil de des différentes étapes lorsque
je veux dire simplement c'est sur la
manière dont on a on aurait pu alors
peut-être même dû contrôler en amont du
21 mai le contenu des demandes
subvention je dis pas qu'elles étaient
toutes problématiques c'est pas du tout
le cas et je pense que la plupart ne
l'était pas d'ailleurs mais il aurait pu
y avoir un appui de la part d'autres
acteurs que simplement le seul agent qui
était chargé d'instruire je crois que au
départ c'est 71 dossiers qui sont reçus
c'est considérable on aurait pu avoir un
appui qui n'a pas eu lieu pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que tout
simplement enfin en tout cas parce qu'il
me concerne moi j'ai pas été associé
effectivement à cette phase de
préparation et d'instruction des
dossiers mais surtout parce que on a un
agent alors je pense que ça a été dit
mais pour nous c'est très important et
j'envoie maintenant les conséquences
c'est que on avait un agent qui n'est
pas directement dans ses fonctions mais
qui a réellement en fait apporté cet
appui pendant pas mal d'années qui était
ce qu'on appelle nous les référents de
contrôle de financier ça
s'appelle RCF pour faire simple référent
de contrôles internes financier c'est un
agent qui est chargé de suivre tout le
processus de dépense de contrôler le
processus de dépense alors en fait par
sondage parce que le contrôle pas je le
dis clairement sans en totalité sans
subventions par an c'est absolument
impossible mais ne serait-ce que par
sondage il a cette fonction de vérifier
que le logigramme dont j'ai parlé a été
respecté c'est à dire que toutes les
ailes les 12 étapes ont bien été
respectées par les agents internes du
secrétaire général mais aussi et ça ce
qu'on appelle le contrôle de deuxième
niveau et ça c'est extrêmement important
de contrôler la réalité de la dépense
notamment les pièces de dépenses les
pièces justificatives de dépenses les
factures les bulletins de salaires
or ça et bien lorsque le fond Marianne
est lancé l'appel à projet depuis
février 2021 il n'y a plus d'argent au
service il n'y a plus d'agence service
jusqu'en de mémoire septembre 2022 et je
lis parce que j'ai participé à la
comment dirais-je recrutement de ce qui
me paraissait indispensable et ça a été
extrêmement compliqué de trouver
quelqu'un qui avait un profil de
connaissance du budget de l'État on a eu
énormément de candidats sur ce poste là
des personnes qui ne venaient
pratiquement que du privé qui était dans
le domaine de la banque de l'audit
bancaire des assurances mais qui ne
connaissaient absolument pas le budget
de l'État et donc il a fallu attendre
septembre 2022 pour enfin trouver
quelqu'un qui va rejoindre ce poste
qui d'ailleurs en ce moment est chargé
du contrôle de plusieurs des
associations que nous ne voulons parler
notamment l'ueppn on a demandé de
transmettre toutes les pêches
justificatives en mars 2023 et aller
dessus en ce moment qui veut dire ce qui
veut dire que vous êtes
heureusement expérimenté mais vous êtes
fraîchement nommé
quand
peu de temps après le fond Marianne va
être mis en place avec entre temps
quelques difficultés là vous avez
expliqué les 39000 euros avec
finalement
un personne enfin oui une personne
ressource qui assure le suivi
vu que j'appellerai du contrôle afin que
vous appelez ainsi contrôle internet
financier donc absence totale de février
pendant 18 mois février 21 septembre
2022 puis vous avez la personne
visiblement également ressources dans le
pôle du comité qui est plutôt la
personne enfin qui a beaucoup de
compétences qui est également quitte en
fin d'année 2021 je crois mais je crois
voilà
donc on va dire qu'il y a des
il y a des indices qui à tous les cas où
des symptômes je sais pas quand on le
voit après qui peut-être explique un
certain nombre de difficultés de celles
que l'on constate à ce moment donc vous
nous avez dit vous ne faites pas partie
du comité de sélection on a bien compris
vous arrivez après coup
par contre vous confirmez bien par la
réunion du 22 avril que les comment
dirais-je les directives le fameux
comment programme en 12 étapes est
appliquée pour l'ensemble des du process
mis en place par le format il y a aucun
oui en tout cas on rappelle
effectivement ces règles j'ai le
compte-rendu je peux vous le mettre à
disposition si vous souhaitez il est là
de bonne qualité mais en tout cas on
voit à peu près les échanges qui avaient
eu lieu ce jour-là mais en fait cet
aspect là c'est un simple rappel ce
jour-là bien entendu ça ça va pas se
révéler suffisant je le dis clairement
alors c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
mais on va dans la foulée d'ailleurs de
cette réunion je pense pas dû se passer
au mois de juin probablement j'ai
partout exactement la trace mais je
pense que c'est juin ou fin mai on va
même mettre en place une formation
spécifique sur un agent de la mi-vélu
d'or c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
mais pour nous ça nous a impacté il a
fallu former il y en a donné des doc
d'ailleurs plus explicite pour expliquer
à cette personne qui allait instruire
tous les dossiers de l'appel à projet
cette fois-ci de la lutte contre le
dérive secteur comment faire pour gérer
recevoir les dossiers d'abord regarder
le contenu d'une demande de subvention
ça j'ai pas de la recevoir il faut
examiner ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur voir
s'il y a pas des incohérences voir des
absurdités et notamment ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure l'excédent possible dans
un budget prévisionnel ce qui arrive
parfois ça c'est les choses à voir où
l'absence de ressources humaines pour
gérer les crédits c'est aussi un indice
qui mérite d'être mise en compte et donc
on va la former cet agent dans un une
phase de formation il y a eu trois deux
réunions un document qui a été élaboré
etc mais c'est l'ami ville c'est pas le
fond Marianne le fond Marianne on estime
que enfin moi j'estime que l'agent qui
connaissances est en mesure d'instruire
ces dossiers malgré la masse de travail
pour elle que ça va représenter c'est
certain voilà la situation d'accord donc
on relève néanmoins que dans deux mails
de l'été 2021 juin et juillet vous vous
interroger donc sur
l'octra d'une subvention de plus de
300.000 euros 330 000 exactement à
hautconsur en commun et vous l'avez
évoqué dans un une partie de vos propos
que l'association aux étonnez qu'elle
soit d'une création récente sans salarié
et a priori sans prévisions de
recrutement
est-ce que c'est de l'expérience que
vous aviez était ce une comment
dirais-je une première pour vous quelle
qu'elle a été
quels ont été les réactions de des
destinataires de vos messages quelle
mesure ont été prises à ce moment-là
alors la question était prise de
financement donc il fallait mettre en
forme et bien entendu une fois que la ça
c'est la règle budgétaire mais une fois
que l'acte étant décidé donc au niveau
ministériel une fois que l'acte est
rédigé est signé des deux parties c'est
un acte d'engagement juridique c'est ce
qu'on appelle un ej en matière
budgétaire donc vachement juridique ça
veut dire que ensuite il y aura une
traduction budgétaire dans l'application
qui s'appelle chorus l'application de
gestion des crédits d'État et donc là il
va y avoir il va y avoir tout à la fois
l'engagement des autorisations
d'engagement les aveux 100% et la
délivrance alors ça c'est des
conventions qui nous sont propres la
délivrance de la consommation d'une
partie des crédits de paiement et donc
on va délivrer l'argent malgré ma
remarque bien entendu parce qu'on peut
pas aller contre difficile à ce stade en
tout cas les temps précisé que c'est pas
parce qu'il y a pas de salarié dans une
association je disais tout à l'heure
qu'elle n'est pas capable de gérer il y
a des bénévoles d'une part sur
l'exécution même de l'action d'ailleurs
enfin c'est ce qui est prévu je crois de
mémoire dans le document qu'on avait
reçu qu'on a vu par la suite il y avait
non pas des recrutements de salariés qui
étaient prévus mais le recours a des
prestataires ce qui est assez classique
dans ce genre d'action où on rémunère
sous forme de factures j'imagine des
prestataires pour faire telle ou telle
action sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui
est effectivement la traduction de
l'action ce qui te suffit au spa en
recrutant de salariés à chaque fois donc
c'est pas inconcevable mais c'est un
élément d'alerte
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'avais
indiqué je crois dans un des mails
concerné en je sais plus c'est en
juillet mais je crois que c'est juillet
2021 que c'était ce type d'action qui
méritait justement peut-être un contrôle
a posteriori sur la réalité de la
consommation des crédits et notamment
dans ce qu'on appelle le contrôle de
deuxième niveau sur piège justificative
qui ne se fait que sur sur des
échantillons on peut pas encore une fois
contrôler l'ensemble des dossiers c'est
affaire en quelque sorte une alerte
voilà parfait
donc
ces choses là étant dites et les alertes
ayant été donnés
donc le visa est donné et donc
l'opération démarre
bien pouvez-vous nous parler de
maintenant de l'exécution de son mariage
comment elle a été assurée après la
sélection des projets finalement et les
premiers inversements de subventions
réalisées autrement dit quel contrôle
avez-vous opéré sur l'ensemble des
projets de manière très globale
avez-vous réalisé un ou des contrôles
sur pièces ou bien prenez-t-il une autre
forme
cette modalité de contrôle sont elles
identiques à ceux que vous avez pu faire
dans d'autres dans d'autres enveloppes
budgétaires versés à des associations
comme le Philippin
alors le contrôle concernant les 17
dossiers de l'appel à projet est
absolument identique enfin doit être
absolument identique et il a été je
pense de ce qui est fait sur l'ensemble
des autres actions financées bien
entendu la question de créer des règles
spécifiques
en fait il y a plus rien double contrôle
il y a ce que nous appelons nous le
contrôle métier qui est un peu le fond
du problème notamment pour l'association
reconstruire le commun c'est un contrôle
sur l'exécution même de l'action j'avoue
je n'ai sur ces sujets et notamment sur
la communication digitale aucune
compétence encore une fois c'est pas mon
domaine et je fais incapable de savoir
ce qui est ce qui vaut un like plus que
notre like je ne sais pas du tout mais
en tout cas ça c'est le rôle
effectivement du pôle dit métier qui a
instruit les dossiers et qui doit
ensuite qui connaît la matière en plus
surtout et qui doit effectivement
regarder un peu l'exécution et la
qualité de la prestation
il y a un autre contrôle et les deux se
rejoignent à un moment donné il y a un
autre contrôle qui est plutôt budgétaire
ou même franchement budgétaire et qui a
qui prend de forme
il y a une forme qui est conventionnelle
c'est-à-dire qui est dans la convention
attributive de subventions c'est
l'article je crois que c'est l'article 4
des modèles de convention qu'on a
utilisé pour le fond Marianne qui on
utilise pour l'ensemble des dossiers
financés et qui
vise finalement à contrôler l'état
déclaratif de dépenses avant de délivrer
ce qu'on appelle le solde de la
subvention alors le soldat subvention
pour être tout à fait précis n'existe
que lorsqu'il y a ces fameuses
conventions au-delà de 23000 euros en
deçà de 23000 euros c'est la règle
budgétaire AE = CP je sais pas si vous
la connaissez mais
on délivre la totalité des engagements
et des crédits de paiement en même temps
donc ça c'est réglé c'est un acte
attribut à l'intrigue unilatéral donc
dans les conventions c'est différent
puisqu'elle effectivement un découpage
en deux
un acompte important 75% pour permettre
le lancement de l'action véritablement
et ensuite un contrôle sur deux
documents qui s'affigurent dans la
convention s'est indiqué noir sur blanc
dans un des articles c'est d'une part
une attestation sur l'honneur du
responsable de l'association de la
structure financée qui indique que la
structure a atteint au moins un taux de
60% de dépenses du budget prévisionnel
qui avait été fourni lors de la demande
de subvention
bien entendu
à ce niveau là à ce stade il n'y a pas
de contrôle sur pièce ces déclaratifs
sauf que enfin là je parle en tant que
pénaliste
quand l'association et son président
surtout signe attestation sur l'honneur
indique qu'il a dépassé si c'est pas la
réalité ça peut poser quand même un
petit problème en matière pénale donc on
rappelle d'ailleurs les textes du Code
pénal sont indiqués que toutes fausses
déclarations peut entraîner
l'application des dispositions sur ce
qui sanctionne le faux et usage de faux
voilà on poursuit un peu je vais
peut-être vous solliciter un peu plus
sur finalement les les associations qui
selon vous ont posé problème donc je
parle bien du contrôle on est dans le
contrôle budgétaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire d'abord
il y en a donc 17 est-ce qu'il y en a 15
qui ne pose pas de problème budgétaire
ou est-ce que vous dériez pas comme ça
et est-ce qu'il y en a deux réellement
qui posent un problème est-ce que c'est
vraiment de nature budgétaire pour liner
pour l'autre ou est-ce que c'est plus
sur les contenus enfin etc comment ça
vous arrive c'est alors sur les je
termine quand même l'explication parce
que c'est un impact si je puis dire un
lien avec la question que vous venez de
poser ce que je viens de décrire c'est
un contrôle conventionnel c'est-à-dire
dispositif conventionnel par contre il y
a des dispositifs légal et là c'est
autre chose c'est l'article 10 de la loi
du 12 avril 2000 sur les relations entre
les administrations et les citoyens qui
a des modifié plusieurs reprises
notamment 2014 c'est important parce que
c'est là qu'on définit d'ailleurs pour
la première fois dans la loi française
ce qu'est une subvention en 2014 ce qui
n'existait pas autrefois et bien là cet
article 10 prévoit que la structure
financée plutôt doit fournir
un document qui s'appelle le
compte-rendu financier le crfi et ça ça
doit se faire en principe en clôture
d'action donc là on a terminé l'action
on n'est pas en cours d'exécution comme
les 60% et j'ai pas par ailleurs là on
est à la fin de l'action et on doit
fournir un compte rendu financier qui
doit attester c'est ce qu'elle dit la
loi de la conformité de la dépense avec
la subvention telle qu'elle a été
accordée voilà mais c'est purement
déclaratif bien entendu à ce stade avec
les mêmes conséquences pénales que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure bien entendu parce
que tout ça c'est signé testé etc et
c'est un document là cette fois-ci qui
est imposé dans les dossiers de l'appel
du fond Marianne les documents que je
viens d'indiquer l'ensemble des
documents que je viens d'indiquer dans
l'ensemble je pense pouvoir le dire à
part deux mais à ce jour sauf erreur on
est encore dans les délais pour les
fournir en ce qui concerne le crfi on a
encore dans les délais
la totalité des documents que je viens
de citer ils sont dans les dossiers ils
ont été fournis donc il y a pas
véritablement de ce point de vue là une
alerte majeure il y a eu des retards ça
c'est exact mais pas une absence totale
de coopération de tel ou telle
association en revanche il y a
effectivement une difficulté qui surgit
sur Gérer sur le plan budgétaire je dis
bien une association qui est l'uspm
et là on est on est plus tard on est
alors je le dis clairement là aussi
autre difficulté sur cette association
le fameux compte-rendu financier doit
être fourni après la loi dans les six
mois de la clôture de l'exercice
budgétaire au cours duquel la subvention
a été accordée terme de la loi du 12
avril 2000 article 10 en réalité dans
nos conventions on est un peu plus
exigeant ça peut discuter d'ailleurs
puisqu'on ne laisse pas se délai là six
mois après la clôture des récits du thé
en cours de Canada on impose le
versement de ce document dans les six
mois de l'achèvement de l'action ce qui
peut être plus court finalement mais en
tout cas ces discutable mais en tout cas
c'est très léger comme ça et en ce qui
concerne l'US oppm le point de départ
c'est un problème pour cette association
le point de départ du délai de six mois
a été considéré
peut-être à tort d'ailleurs comme étant
la date exacte du 31 mai 2022
parce que est intervenu dans ce dossier
une demande d'avenant je parlais tout à
l'heure des avenants de prolongation des
délais d'achèvement c'est le cas pour
cette association est intervenu une
demande pour prolonger de mémoire de
trois mois je crois le délai d'exécution
de l'action entre c'était le 28 février
2022 qui était la date inscrite au
départ et le 31 mai donc 3 mois de plus
pour terminer l'action sauf que ce
document il a été accepté sur le
principe c'était accepté par le
secrétaire général et le secrétaire
général lui-même d'ailleurs mais en
revanche on a jamais pu retrouver et les
investigations récentes l'ont montrées
la trace d'un document signé
l'association qui aurait été retournée
au secrétaire général signé dont par le
président malgré une relance puisqu'on a
les mails de relance etc et il n'a
jamais répondu donc la question se pose
savoir finalement quel est le vrai délai
n'empêche que à tort ou à raison on a
considéré que c'était le 31 mai
et du coup c'est dans les six mois qu'on
aurait dû être fourni le fameux
compte-rendu financier d'après l'article
10 de la loi de 2000 et ce document en
2023 en février 2023 il était toujours
pas fourni et donc c'est là où je parle
de la budgétaire parce par rapport à
cette association c'est là où je vais
intervenir c'est en février 2023 c'est
avant d'ailleurs que n'éclate je lis bon
passons au passage mais quand même c'est
avant qu'une éclate effectivement
l'aspect public la difficulté avec ces
associations c'est exactement je crois
le 14 février 2023 où je suis alerté par
le pôle qui gère
Fuji de l'action donc le pôle métier qui
est l'ucidaire unité de contre l'Esco
républicain sachant que je l'ai pas dit
jusqu'à présent c'est ce pôle qui doit
recevoir les documents budgétaires avant
de les transmettre au pôle dont j'ai la
responsabilité c'est ce pôle là c'est ce
pôle là depuis cette service là depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
n'arrive pas à avoir la restitution des
documents demandés et donc le 14 février
c'est très précis parce que ça
correspond à des mails que j'ai envoyé
je suis alerté par le responsable de
chez Paul par le chef du pôle en disant
qu'ils ont des difficultés avec l'uspm
pour obtenir notamment le compte-rendu
financier
et donc je vais donner des éléments que
j'ai en tête parce que là ils sont assez
précis je téléphone j'arrive à trouver
le numéro de téléphone je téléphone au
Président
vous avez le nom je pense Clarin lagaran
j'arrive à l'avoir au téléphone alors
qu'il ne répondait pas au téléphone
semble-t-il précédemment à mes collègues
de l'autre vol je le dis au passage et
je lui fais remarquer qu'effectivement
on n'a pas reçu le compte rendu
financier mais surtout je découvre c'est
là où il y a effectivement une certaine
difficulté je découvre que les autres
documents qui ont été fournis je pense
alors je ne sais pas exactement la date
mais c'était en 2022 ça c'est sûr qui
sont l'état des dépenses qui auraient pu
justifier le cas échéant le versement du
solde puisque ils auraient pu justifier
qu'ils avaient atteint 60% des fameuses
dépenses en fait ces documents ont bien
été fournis mais ils révèle que ce seuil
de 60% n'a jamais été atteint jamais
et donc lors de la conversation
téléphonique je fais état de cet aspect
là avec le président et je lui explique
en l'état c'est pas possible de verser
le solde il n'a pas rempli les
conditions conventionnelles et donc je
lui demande ensuite alors ça fait
l'objet d'un écrit de ma part parce que
je couvre évidemment on appelle
téléphone par un mail et je demande de
me transmettre le fameux compte-rendu
financier qu'il aurait dû fournir au
moins depuis novembre 2022 et que le
pôle les collègues du pôle métier
n'arrive pas à obtenir et je lui fais
enfin je lui fais remarquer par écrit
que en l'état l'action est en terminé de
toute façon elle est terminée on ne
pourra pas verser le solde ça sera pas
possible et je lui demande même de
renoncer expressément pour couvrir tout
risque de contentieux parce que c'est
jamais ça peut parfois être le cas et
c'est ce qu'il va faire il va envoyer le
compte rendu financier je crois le
lendemain sur le 15 février avec
effectivement de sa part en indication
sur laquelle il renonce à tenir le sol
donc là il y a un problème budgétaire
c'est clair donc si vous nous dites s'il
y a eu un retard si je peux dire à
l'allumage entre novembre aurait dû être
la fin de la Convention et février vous
intervenez c'est parce que le pôle
métier finalement vous dit j'ai quelques
difficultés mais ça va arriver enfin bon
on peut je sais pas et en tout cas ça
vous renvoie à février où ils vous
disent là on n'y arrive pas c'est ça le
sujet exactement ok
par contre sur les au niveau des
contrôles vous amenez un sur une autre
association qui s'appelle Civic Fab et
finalement c'est la première association
sur laquelle vous allez faire un
contrôle un peu approfondie c'est comme
ça qu'il faut lire les choses donc ce
qu'il pouvait nous étonner c'est de
finalement entre
deux associations l'une qui avait des
problèmes financiers que vous relevez en
février 2023 et
la deuxième qui avait des problèmes de
contenu sur lequel il y avait une
difficulté qui ont dû transpirer jusqu'à
votre service ni même c'est à dire
l'association
sur le commun je perds toujours son nom
reconstruire le commun
malgré tous ces pas ces deux
associations là qui font l'objet d'un
contrôle c'est ça mais c'est plutôt la
troisième que je viens de citer
est-ce que est-ce que tout ça est quand
même assez logique finalement dans votre
esprit alors logique pas toujours en
discuter mais en fait six Fab a posé une
autre difficulté qui était alors qu'il
apparaît pas peut-être manière très
lisible mais en tout cas que j'ai
rencontré c'est que là aussi à partir
des lectures des documents budgétaires
transmis par cette association il
apparaissait que on n'aurait pas dû
verser le solde de l'association
toujours
j'avais donné des instructions pour ne
pas le faire sauf que bon ben si c'était
trop sur le sujet mais par
une action malencontreuse dans des
agents enfin de mon poste j'en parlerai
responsabilité c'est clair en fait ce
soit la bien été versée et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle quand a arrive pour
la première fois à nouveau un
responsable du contrat de financier en
septembre 2022 en novembre 2022 ensemble
on regarde les dossiers qui posent
difficultés et comme j'avais indiqué par
écrit que compte tenu de cette versement
il y aurait matière à contrôler cette
association qui s'appelle sanctivite Fab
elle est retenue parmi trois
associations d'ailleurs pour faire
l'objet d'un contrôle approfondi il y en
a il y en a deux autres il y a pas que
c'est une femme également une
association on parle pas ici c'est la
raison de pourquoi les tempêtes voilà
voilà c'est notre question alors on va
poursuivre alors peut-être avant on a
une ou deux questions sur un Vernay
c'est sur cette partie là
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Lafitte j'aimerais savoir puisque le
montant des subventions en tout cas pour
les deux associations concernées dépasse
153000 euros est-ce que vous avez
vérifié qu'un commissaire au compte
avait été nommé est-ce que dans la
procédure de contrôle vous avez vérifié
ça ce qu'il y avait un commissaire aux
comptes et ce que vous avez eu des
échanges par rapport à ça alors
commissaire au compte en principe oui
enfin dans les documents qu'on demande
effectivement il y a soit comment
dirais-je l'obligation de verser
notamment quand on n'est pas 153000
euros de verser les les comptes annuels
et le bilan sous forme du plan comptable
associatif
plus effectivement le rapport du
commissaire augmente alors normalement
c'est dossiers comportent ces documents
là je peux pas affirmer parce que j'ai
pas en tête à la totalité du contenu de
chacun des dossiers mais normalement la
plupart en tout cas de ces dossiers
comporte ces éléments là par contre en
dessous de 253000 euros les associations
n'ont pas l'obligation de dé
merci
je vais revenir à l' udppm donc vous
nous avez vous avez bien évoqué votre
action et réaction du 14 février 2023
qui est suivi un mois après
d'une d'un contact que vous avez avec
cette association pour
l'informer de ce qu'elle va avoir un
contrôle sur pièce donc
ça vous paraît vous les informer donc là
je dirais très rapidement eu égard aux
éléments vous nous avez donné déjà
prolongation liée à l'avenant parce que
vous pensez que
enfin vous avez certainement des doutes
sur comment dirais-je le fonctionnement
de l'association c'est ça et des doutes
et même des craintes en fait ce qui
s'est passé il y a une autre étape entre
ces deux étapes si je puis dire qui se
situe en jeu pu la date mais je crois
que c'est aux alentours du 14 mars il me
semble c'est que nous avons reçu enfin
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure le fameux
compte-rendu financier donc on l'a entre
les mains etc sauf que en lui disant je
note que
une première partie dans ces documents
c'est les documents de formalisés c'est
énorme alizés ce sont des cerfs donc il
y a d'un chapitre il faut remplir c'est
tout simple enfin en tout cas c'est
extrêmement contraignant quand même pour
l'association dans la rédaction et il y
a une partie qui est la première partie
qui n'est pas remplie
qui est le bilan tout simplement le
bilan de l'action
il n'y a pas de mention il y a un budget
enfin budget final qui apparaît des
quelques commentaires mais la première
partie n'est pas rempli et donc je
renvoie un mail en disant bah attendez
je suis désolé mais il manque le bilan
le bilan quelle quantitatif voir
qualitatif qui doit figurer là-dedans et
donc ça c'est je le répète aux alentours
du 14 mars 15 mars ou 14 mars et
il y a pas de réponse au bout de je sais
plus quelques jours trois quatre jours
aucune réponse et c'est là que j'envoie
alors cette fois-ci un deuxième
troisième ou 4e mail je sais plus où
j'indique effectivement constatant
l'absence de réponse et en plus d'autres
documents n'ont pas été fournis
notamment les bilans les bilans le
rapport au commissaire aux comptes nous
n'avons pas les bilans 2021 nous n'ont
pas les bilans 2022 ce que j'ai demandé
puisque l'exercice c'était allé sur deux
exercices budgétaires
et bien c'est là que j'indique que vu
ces éléments ces absences d'éléments
c'est un contrôle sur pièce qui va être
déclenché en application de l'article 8
de la Convention d'accord donc le
comment dirais-je l'absence d'éléments
concernant le bilan d'action qui est
le rendu objectif fait par l'association
elle-même donc ça confirme c'est ce qui
déclenche votre réaction puisque
d'ailleurs vous aviez donc vous
confirmez là que le bilan quand il tâtif
et qualitatif insuffisance que vous
aviez noté donc si
d'aventure il était dit que le bilan de
cette association à ce moment-là est bon
voire positif
quel serait votre réaction vous
confirmeriez que
inexact enfin moi je peux pas affirmer
quoi que ce soit sur le fond parce que
c'est pas quelque chose que je maîtrise
très précisément encore une fois on est
dans un domaine qui est relativement
formel qui sont des tableaux à remplir
des documents formalisés également des
indications de tête portée par contre le
contenu même de l'action là il faut
effectivement associer forcément des
personnes qui sont chez nous qui sont
plus à même de donner une appréciation
ça concerne cette association sans
concerne aussi une autre manifestement
et là moi j'ai pas forcément de regard à
porter en revanche ça concerne plutôt de
l'autre association que l'USPPM si la
réalisation de l'action s'est écartée de
l'objet même qui avait été défini dans
la convention là il y a ma terre à
remettre en cause l'attribution la
subvention c'est un autre sujet ça et
dans le cas de l'ucpm c'est un problème
budgétaire c'est-à-dire qu'encore une
fois même s'ils avaient rempli
correctement le fameux bilan dans la
partie 1 du compte rendu financier ça
n'aurait rien changé en non versement du
solde puisque de toute façon il y a une
rempl issait pas les conditions
conventionnelles
d'accord je veux peut-être juste dans le
corps dans l'exécution financière 202122
donc on voit bien que cette association
présente finalement
plusieurs signes d'inquiétude et
l'annonce un soutien une subvention de
la Région
des régions pardon de 145 000 euros
d'aide privée autour de 45000 euros on
voit bien que un certain nombre de
charges sont sous exécutés qui a donc
toujours pas de personnel pardon et
qu'il n'y en fait plus que des charges
de personnel puisqu'elles atteignent au
global une exécution à 87% en 2022
est-ce que finalement
ça rejoint le la question que j'ai posée
avant est-ce que le bilan de
l'association c'est pas surtout des
charges de personnel
alors en soi je crois qu'il faut quand
même être un peu distancé par rapport
aux éléments d'alerte si je puis dire de
ces associations là ou tel ou tel en
soit le fait de payer du personnel pour
travailler sur des réseaux sociaux ce
n'est pas forcément choquant en soi
il peut y avoir des achats de matériel
c'est sûr il peut y avoir des
imputations de charges fixes la location
d'un local une partie d'assurance qu'il
faut assurer qui peut être imputé et
c'est tout à fait régulier sur une
partie de l'action en tout cas ça ce que
dans un montant raisonnable et adapté à
la charge que représente pour
l'association la réalisation c'est tout
à fait normal et encore une fois les
charges de personnel elles étaient
présentes je crois de mémoire dès le
début dans le de la demande de
subvention il y avait une indication
assez précise d'ailleurs sur des
recrutements de personnes de salariés
alors de mémoire c'était froid six
personnes dans la dernière version du
document qu'on avait reçu il devait y
avoir deux contrats à durer indéterminés
les noms ne figureraient pas une figure
jamais d'ailleurs dans les demandes de
subventions jamais il y a des noms de
personnel s à recruter bien entendu mais
par contre il y avait deux contrats du
réindéterminés et je crois 4 durées à
contrat déterminées donc c'était pas
forcément choquant qu'une large partie
de la subvention servent à je sais pas
moi recruter des community manager ou
que sais-je c'était pas forcément le cas
par contre on avait encore une fois pas
les noms enfin moi j'avais pas les noms
évidemment des personnes qui allaient
recruter à ce SATA et puis surtout moi
j'avais pas un sweet de dossier à ce
stade donc je n'avais pas forcément une
connaissance précise de ce qui allait
ensuite générer les charges mais elles
étaient pas incohérentes
d'accord juste une très courte question
vous avez déjà quelques enseignements
[Musique]
débuts d'évaluation sur le contrôle que
vous avez lancé à la mi-mars de cette
année
alors il y a des documents nombreux qui
ont été fournis je veux dire ils ont été
fournis pour les analyser après c'est à
peu près de plus de 200 documents qui
ont été envoyés par transfert peu
importe
pour le moment je peux pas faire grand
chose il y a des bulletins de salaire
nombreux alors moi j'avais là je suis
parti maintenant des services mais
j'avais demandé quand je satisfasse pas
contenu de contexte des bulletins de
salaires mais connaît aussi les contrats
de travail alors ça moi je les ai pas vu
je le dis franchement je ne les ai pas
je les ai pas vu en tout cas j'avais
demandé quand les quand les demandes en
plus et donc j'imagine que ça va être
fait les bulletins de salaire certains
oui sont effectivement manifestement en
lien avec des personnalités
identifiées dans l'association enfin
deux personnalités
et des montants de l'ordre j'ai regardé
enfin j'ai pas les noms mais en tout cas
on voit apparaître les montants dans il
y a un tableau synoptique aussi on voit
classer par année la totalité des
charges puisque dans la convention enfin
je dis au passage il y a une exigence
supplémentaire au-delà des contrôles
c'est d'avoir un outil analytique c'est
l'article si je crois de la convention
qui prévoit un outil analytique et
effectivement l'association nous a
restitués des tableaux Excel où on voit
par année par classés par catégorie des
montants différentes charges après ça
vérifier ce que ça correspond ça
correspond bien à l'action qu'on a
financé ça c'est autre chose et donc on
voit apparaître des montants de salaire
de l'ordre de 3000 je crois un peu plus
de 3000 euros pour les plus importants
il y en a deux manifestement et un autre
un peu plus important qui doit être lors
de 3900 ou 3500 € je crois sur plusieurs
mois et ça débute à partir de juin dès
qu'on a délivré finalement les premiers
crédits de paiement comme les a consommé
donc en juin 2021 on voit apparaître
effectivement ces bulletins de salaire
dans les tableaux qu'on a obtenus voilà
mais après il faut quand même vérifier
évidemment tout le reste qu'il s'agit
très bien merci quelques questions pour
reconstruire le commun alors des choses
d'abord très simples il y a eu des
réunions il y a eu des réunions en
particulier sur les contenus il y a eu
des discussions sur les contenus
éventuellement des messages soi-disant
politique ou reconnus d'ailleurs comme
nature politique est-ce que vous avez
été associé à cette ce travail-là cette
réflexion là ou pas du tout alors
pas exactement sur cette forme mais par
contre et ça c'est important il y a une
réunion à laquelle on m'a demandé de
participer alors j'ai du mal à la situer
pour moi elle est en mars 2022 mais avec
quelques nuances je pense que c'est ça
ou effectivement la question de comment
dirais-je de la qualité du produit en
quelque sorte
l'aspect politique enfin moi j'ai pas du
tout souvenir que cet aspect était
abordé alors peut-être manière incidente
mais c'était pas le sujet le sujet à
cette époque là c'était une faible
pénétration finalement sur le réseau
sociaux un nombre d'adhésion d'adhérents
ces critères qui ont été acceptés
puisque c'est un document qui est le
CERFA qui est dupliqué un joli
clairement c'est du copier-coller
c'est-à-dire que quand on fait on met en
forme l'acte attributif sauf difficulté
majeures repérées on reprend les termes
de la du CERFA qui est la demande de
subvention et on l'intègre en annexe
dans la convention elle-même donc on
reprend les termes or dans la partie
concernant les critères d'évaluation les
termes qui ont été acceptés donc le 21
mai 2021
sélections sont je dirais relativement
vague voire très vague j'ai le souvenir
notamment il y a dans les critères il y
a un critère qui s'appelle
évaluation de qualitative
et la traduction dans la convention
c'est évaluation qualitative
évidemment avec des
critères de cette nature c'est M
extrêmement compliqué de remettre en
cause le non respect de l'évaluation
telle qu'elle est prévue à la Convention
donc j'avais dit à cette réunion j'ai
dit que c'était un peu compliqué qu'il
fallait faire suivre l'évolution mais
que ça me paraissait difficile de
remettre en cause le principe même de la
subvention qui avait été accordé avec un
acte signé et des parties on risquait un
contentieux là c'est un monde délicat
donc à ce stade là on en est resté là
mais encore une fois j'ai pas du tout le
souvenir alors je répète ça peut être
évoqué de manière incidente mais c'était
pas le sale le sujet majeur j'ai pas le
souvenir que des aspects alors par
contre de contenu politique ait été le
point central des échanges à ce
moment-là mars 2022
après il y a eu d'autres échanges mais
moi j'ai découvert par la suite je le
dis j'ai pas été associé effectivement
cet aspect là surgit d'une manière
beaucoup plus nette et là j'ai pas été
directement
et donc suite à votre raisonnement
je suis votre raisonnement qui
finalement les 25% qui restaient ont été
vers
globalement les conditions financières
étaient remplies administratives on va
dire
le sujet est un peu ténu
sur la question de fond est-ce que c'est
et donc bon on paye quoi et finalement
après une fois avoir payé tout ça et
avoir constaté des difficultés qui se
poursuivaient on demande de leur
remboursement pour le remboursement
c'est le rapporteur qui va y venir
vous pouvez estimer
à ce stade quel montant quel est le
montant de la réclamation ou de retour
que vous attendez alors d'abord la
procédure en fait dans les conventions
mais c'est pour une partie de la
traduction de terme budgétaire classique
il y a deux méthodes
soit la méthode verte un peu brutale qui
est l'émission d'un titre de perception
c'est-à-dire que l'État émet un type de
perception en raison d'un à l'issue
d'une procédure contradictoire parce que
attention là aussi il faut respecter
qu'un certain nombre de formes on ne
fait pas cela sans recevoir les
observations de la partie adverse si je
puis dire il y a une deuxième méthode
mais en l'espace qui n'est pas qui n'a
pas vocation à mon sens à être utilisé
qu'on a utilisé parfois pour éviter les
missions de l'équipe de perception et
toute la posture très lourde qui va
derrière
j'ai expérimenté il y a quelques mois et
ça a été extrêmement compliqué je le dis
au passage en fait on a un le
trop-perçu calcule notre perçu on a pu
se trop perçu sur le montant de la
subvention
s'il y a un renouvellement qui va venir
l'année suivante et donc on réduit
finalement le montant et c'est prévu
dans un des articles de la Convention
c'est prévu expressément bon là c'est
pas le cas dans le cas qu'on évoque
évidemment on est sur le terme classique
a priori de l'émission de type de
perception alors pour le moment à ce
stade je ne peux pas vous indiquer quel
est le montant qui va faire l'objet d'un
restitution au profit de l'État ce qui
est demandé parce qu'il envisagé en tout
cas quand je quitté le service mais en
tout cas c'était le dernier étape quand
j'étais là j'étais présent c'était de
calculer très précisément le coût qu'a
représenté et l'imputation surtout
budgétaire qui a représenté pour la
subvention toutes les prestations qui se
sont écartées de l'objet de la
Convention et a priori d'après les
échanges pour l'instant informel que
j'ai eu avec des collègues qui
travaillent plus en lien avec les
réseaux sociaux donc la fameuse ucdr
c'est a priori calculable parce que ils
ont dans la convention je crois que ça
fasse dans la dans les documents fournis
budgétaires par l'association au tout
départ il y a des montants par
prestation et donc on sait qu'une vidéo
coûte temps etc alors je sais plus quel
est le montant je crois c'est 6000 euros
par vidéo ou je ne sais trop donc on
doit être en mesure à ce stade de
calculer précisément dans un cas de
contradictoire parce qu'il va falloir le
notifier il faudra recevoir les
observations de la partie adverse et moi
j'ai lancé la procédure en ce sens
récemment avec une courrier recommandée
qui est parti je croyais trois quatre
jours et où effectivement on va recevoir
les observations de la partie adverse
sur ce montant et pour l'instant à mon
sens il n'est pas encore calculé
très bien merci alors j'ai Isabelle
briquet puis
Daniel broyer
le président bonjour c'est la vie
une petite question on a évoqué tout à
l'heure là la subvention de 39000 euros
enfin verser fin 2020 enfin plutôt de
billes début 2021 et
lors des de la présentation de cette
de cette subvention quand on a commencé
à parler du fond Marianne et tout il a
été le secrétaire général
a dit que cette subvention avait été
versée enfin alors fin d'année 2020 peu
importe à la limite pour accompagner le
lancement de cette de cette association
l'association étant reconstruire le
commun
cependant enfin le choix de financer la
création d'une association s'inscrit
quand même en contradiction avec le
principe même du fond
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance qui vise à procéder projets
et pas directement les structures
ainsi les il est stipulé dans les
différents documents et formulaires que
la prise en charge des frais de
structure ne peut dépasser 10% des
frangins par les associations donc la
question est double sur cette subvention
39000 euros qu'est-ce qui a pu justifier
la dérogation faite au profit de
reconstruire en commun pour cette
subvention 39000 et pour la suite sur le
fond Marianne les subventions apportées
aussi bien à reconstruire le commun
calu c'est lui cette ppm
ont-elles ou non couvert une part
supérieure à 10% des charges de
fonctionnement administratifs des deux
associations enfin d'autres termes
est-ce qu'on a financé des projets ou
bien des structures associatives
au passage que j'essaie de rappeler
souvent parce que il y a souvent
certaines confusions sur le rôle du fond
interministériel qui est c'est pas tout
à fait des crédits d'une réhabituels
c'est important de le rappeler le fond
interministériel est défini dans son
objet par la loi ce qui est pas le cas
de tous les programmes budgétaires de
l'État il n'y a pas une loi spéciale par
rapport au programme et là il y a une
loi l'article 5 de la loi du 5 mars 2016
qui dit qu'effectivement le FIPD le fond
interministériel finance des actions de
prévention de la délinquance de
prévention de la radicalisation depuis
ça a été un peu élargi mais ce sont des
actions ou des projets et ça c'est un
point important alors je n'ai pas
assisté
au moment où cadre dans laquelle a été
décidé cette fameuse subvention de 39000
euros je ne sais pas pendant quelle
commission ça c'est déroulé puisque je
répète j'ai pas trouvé de trace en tout
cas des conditions mais en tout cas la
convention elle a bien été signée passée
ce qui est sûr c'est que au-delà du
fonctionnement moi je pense que c'est
pas exactement comme ça quelque chose se
présentent dans la convention que j'ai
lu j'ai lu je sais pas si elle vous a
été adressée j'ai un doute d'ailleurs
mais c'est pas le fonctionnement de
l'action enfin de l'association qui
décrite comme étant l'objet de la
suspension c'est la création d'un site
internet avec des contenus qui sont
listés qui sont indiqués alors après
reste à savoir ce qui a été réellement
fait ça c'est autre chose mais en tout
cas c'est bien une action qui est
décrite dans la convention et ça je l'ai
vérifié voilà donc pour moi c'était
plutôt formellement je dis bien
formellement plutôt régulier mais voilà
c'est une action faite dans le cadre du
lancement d'une association tourner
comme ça très bien
Daniel broyer merci bonjour monsieur da
Fidget en fait j'ai deux questions la
première c'est est-ce fréquent
d'attribuer une subvention intime une
convention avec une association qui n'a
pas d'existence préalable
enfin j'avoue j'étais mère 20 ans je
n'ai jamais subventionné d'associations
qui n'avait pas fait une preuve
préalable de de son action de sa
constitution et donc je comprends sur
cette association qu'au fond accompagne
sa création est-ce que j'ai mal compris
les les propos ou est-ce que c'est exact
et ma deuxième question vous nous avez
décrit avec rigueur un processus
d'élaboration et de questionnements pour
vos collaborateurs sur le suivi des
attributions de subventions des analyses
de dossiers de subvention très élaborée
et vous nous avez indiqué que en 2020 de
mémoire le cabinet de Madame sciapa fait
remonter à son niveau l'attribution de
subventions est-ce que les cabinet dans
ce cas là est soumis à au suivi de des
procédures qui ont été définies par
votre direction
alors sur
la deuxième question s'il vous permettez
en fait le document qui faisait
référence à l'époque quand l'appel à
projet a été lancé c'était un document
qui datait de 2019
n'avait pas été remis à jour
non c'est un document qui datait donc de
2019 qui n'avait pas été remis à jour et
donc le cabinet ministériel n'apparaît
pas dans ce document c'est toute la
difficulté donc quand en avril 2021
semble-t-il pour la première fois le
cabinet ministériel fait élever à son
niveau la prise de décision le document
qui fait référence n'est pas à jour je
le dis clairement il est aujourd'hui je
l'ai mis à jour moi il y a quelques
jours avec une note de service interne
dans la totalement revu le document mais
encore une fois c'est la situation de
2021 voilà il n'est pas impliqué dans le
dispositif puisqu'il n'existe pas encore
dans ce document là en 2019
ensuite la première question que vous
aviez posé qui concernait le lancement
enfin en tout cas l'accompagnement de
l'association moi j'ai pas l'observation
à faire j'ai pas participé à cette prise
de décision je constate qu'il y a une
convention qui a été signée le 28
décembre 2020 une association et c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait un mail d'ailleurs
en ce sens on a dit quand que je
m'étonnais de la brièveté de d'existence
de cette association pour lui attribuer
non pas 39000 euros mais 330
000 35 voilà bon c'est tout ce que je
peux dire je constate cette situation
voilà elle vient de se créer je crois en
octobre il me semble 2020 et en décembre
elle reçoit 39000 euros et en avril elle
reçoit 300 quelques mille euros voilà
c'est la situation merci sur la porte
aux gens dernière parce que comme je
voulais juste revenir sur pour bien
comprendre
vous nous avez dit que le fond Marianne
l'attribution des subventions ce qui
relevait avant comment dirige dans la
décision du comité à l'arrivée de la
ministre ça avait été il avait été
décidé que ça passe de compétences
ministérielles c'est ça vous paraissait
où ça vous paraît encore aujourd'hui
justifier il y avait selon vous vous
pensez où vous avez entendu
[Musique]
comment dirais-je le des raisons pour
expliquer ce changement parce que on
pourrait penser que les sommes ne sont
pas selon les cas parfois on les trouve
très élevés
comparativement et au regard des
responsabilités est-ce que ça vous
paraît bien que ça relève directement
d'une décision de ministérielle bon moi
j'ai pas juger des décisions
ministérielles bien entendu mais il y a
effectivement des éléments je dirais qui
interroge enfin en tout cas qui peuvent
soulever un certain nombre de débats sur
ce sujet
lors de la terre la dépense par exemple
qui est lors de la terre de la dépense
c'est le secrétaire général c'est lui
qui est responsable du Bob les budgets
opérationnel de le programme et c'est
lui qui signe des actes attributifs
c'est son statut c'est pas la ministre
c'est pas les actes attributifs voilà ça
c'est une réalité budgétaire après ce
qui est quand même assez il faut bien
l'avoir en tête cet aspect là je crois
c'est qu'en 2020 il y a un changement
assez radical dans les liaisons
ministères administration si je puis
dire c'est que c'est la première fois je
pense ne pas me tromper qu'un ministre
qu'une ministre en espèces a épouse
exactement les compétences de notre
service c'est à dire que ça son décret
l'attribution
quand je dis d'épouse c'est pas tout à
fait exact parce que c'est compétences
déborde elle traite aussi de la
citoyenneté mais aussi surtout de
l'asile je crois de l'immigration enfin
je ne sais plus en tout cas c'est pas du
tout une compétences mais n'empêche que
nos compétences sont totalement définies
dans le décret d'attribution de la
ministre donc ça veut dire que le lien
est très fort pour la première fois
entre un ministre ou une ministre et un
service administratif qui c'est vrai
parfois est un du mal à qualifier
exactement j'essaie PDR c'est quelque
chose sur laquelle parfois on
s'interroge c'est sur ces missions
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le j'essaie Bel-Air
mais distribue des crédits mais il faut
pas que ça il est d'abord des politiques
il rédigent des stratégies nationales et
j'en sais quelque chose parce que j'en
ai rédigé une voilà et là on a ministre
qui est très en lien directement avec
nos attributions il y a notre aspect
aussi alors qui est très humain si je
peux dire mais ça je pense
l'explication est là vraisemblablement
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec l'aspect
administratif au budgétaire c'est qu'en
fait lorsque le cabinet se met en place
en 2020 le cabinet madame Schiappa
deux collègues à nous qui était membres
du secrétariat général monte au cabinet
et que bien entendu ils ont participé
eux au comité de programmation précédent
ils connaissent le mécanisme ils
connaissent la gestion du FIBD ils ont
eu à y travailler et à participer au
comité et donc je pense que c'est
probablement là l'explication je peux
pas l'affirmer je garderai bien d'être
affirmatif mais je vois quelque chose
d'assez logique c'est qu'ils ont
expliqué comment fonctionnait la gestion
des crédits centraux du FIPD et que
évidemment le cabinet ministériel a
peut-être trouvé logique qu'à un moment
donné et puis savoir Un Certain Regard
politique ce que ça a des incidences
évidemment on comprend bien sur l'usage
des crédits d'État
juste une dernière question très
technique quand on parle du seuil de 60%
pour obtenir le complément de subvention
c'est 60%, il faut justifier de 60% de
la consommation de la subvention ou de
60% de programme c'est 60% en fait des
dépenses prévisionnelles dans la demande
de subvention c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
dans la demande il y a je sais pas moi
il peut y avoir qu'une partie financée
par la subvention
merci beaucoup monsieur Lafitte merci
d'avoir encore une fois
patienté
dans la première étape et merci pour
tout ce que vous avez amené chers
collègues merci de votre patience
également
voilà pour cette audition de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur le
fond Marianne les sénateurs auditionnés
Jean-Pierre Lafitte l'actuel secrétaire
général adjoint du comité inter
ministériel de la prévention de la
radicalisation et de la délinquance
Jean-Pierre Lafitte qui a expliqué au
sénateur comment il avait alerté très
tôt sur le fonctionnement suspect de
certaines associations bénéficiaires de
ce fond Marianne voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivie
continuez à suivre l'actualité politique
et parlementaire sur notre site internet
public sénat.fr je vous souhaite une
très bonne journée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]